>> Laura: NOW IT'S TIME FOR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT TODAY.
WE EXPOSE THE CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
A CATHOLIC COLLEGE HAS KILLED
ITS MASCOT OF ALMOST 100 YEARS.
DISNEY REMAKING A MAJOR
ATTRACTION IN THE NAME OF ME,
TOO, AND THE POLITICAL ART OF
JIM CARREY.
TO EXPLAIN IT ALL, RAYMOND
ARROYO, NUMBER THREE COMING OUT
SOON.
THIS IS CRAZY.
LET'S GO TO JIM CARREY.
AT LEAST FORMER FUNNY MAN?
>> FORMER FUNNY MAN.
>> Laura: PET DETECTIVE,
POLITICAL CARTOON.
IS HE SITTING IN A ROOM BY
HIMSELF --
>> HE RELEASED THESE STRANGE
IMAGES, FIRST OF SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS.
WE'LL PUT IT ON THE SCREEN.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS DRAWN IN AN
INSANE ASYLUM OR SOMETHING.
HE WROTE NASTY THINGS.
THIS IS A PORTRAIT OF A
SO-CALLED CHRISTIAN WHOSE ONLY
PURPOSE IS TO LIE FOR THE
WICKED, MONSTROUS.
HE GOT ATTACKED FOR THAT
NATURALLY, BIGOTED,
ANTI-CHRISTIAN.
THEN HE RELEASED AN IMAGE OF
DONALD TRUMP THIS WEEK, WICKED
WITCH OF THE WEST WING.
>> Laura: THAT'S NOT EVEN FUNNY.
WHAT?
IT LOOKS LIKE FREDDY KRUEGER
WITH THE -- JASON?
NO, FREDDY KRUEGER.
>> WE DUG INTO THE VIDEO ARCHIVE
AND FOUND SEINFELD TALKING TO
JIM CARREY WALKING INTO THE
INESANCTUM.
>> THIS IS THE WORLD FOR ME.
I JUST LOVE PAINT.
I LOVE THE COLORS, I LOVE
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT.
YEAH, THE GIRL WITH THE MACHINE
GUN.
I'VE GOT POWER NOW.
>> Laura: LOOKS LIKE A MURDER
SCENE.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S SO SAD.
FIRST OF ALL, I WISH HIS MOVIES
GOT AS MUCH ATTENTION AS THE
POLITICAL CARTOONS.
HE HAS INSPIRED ME, LAURA.
I RESUMED MY OWN POLITICAL ART
TODAY.
JIM CARREY, SMOKING NO MORE.
AND I HAVE ANOTHER ILLUSTRATION
TO SHARE WITH YOU LATER.
BUT WHAT'S SO SAD, HE WAS THE
COMIC HEIR TO MY JERRY LEWIS.
GO BACK TO STEAL SOMEBODY'S
LINE, SHUT UP AND CLOWN.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
HOLY CROSS.
HOLY CROSS COLLEGE.
NOW, WHY IS HOLY CROSS, THIS IS
IN MASSACHUSETTS, SPRINGFIELD,